the u.n secretary general came to the
ukrainian port city of odessa to see for
himself the grain being loaded onto
ships
the deal between ukraine and russia to
open the waters to cargo ships and to
relieve the global food crisis is pretty
much the only diplomatic success in this
six-month war so far
but there is now another crisis and it's
getting worse by the day the fate of
europe's largest nuclear power plant
near zaparija which has been occupied by
russian forces since march
fighting around the site threatens a
nuclear disaster and a blame game is at
play
both ukraine and russia blame each other
for bombing the zaparisian nuclear power
plant what do you think the truth is and
today there are reports that russia
is planning to
divert the electricity from the power
plant to the russian grid with that in
mind what's your message for moscow
if we demilitarize as we propose
the plant
the problem will be solved
zaporizia is ukrainian electricity and
it's necessary especially during the
winter for the ukrainian people and
these
principles must be fully respected
russia has rejected the idea of
demilitarization and has claimed that
the power plant is actually safer with
russian forces there
ukrainians living nearby don't feel that
way
watching
the french president emmanuel macron
spoke with vladimir putin on the phone
this afternoon to try and find a
breakthrough but all attempts to get
independent inspectors onto the site
have so far failed
recent satellite images taken in the
last few days show no signs of major
shelling or damage
russia's control of the power plant puts
putin in a powerful position he's
unlikely to give it up easily
alistair model sky news in odessa